[Musique]
on est chez universal pour les locaux de
chez jungle
plus précisément dans la série on est
venu pour signer notre premier contrat
aujourd'hui et moi en tant que manager
je suis là pour négocier je suis d'abord
pour faire monter les enchères en fait
en sorte qu'au ministre dans les moeurs
pollution mon ap réfléchit on veut cent
mille euros
cent mille euros pour clément plus
trente mille euros pour mon manager et
10000 euros pour mon community manager
manager de clément dans le sens où il a
la tête sur les épaules
c'était fade écouté il va vous laisser
réfléchir comme ça nous ça nous laisse
que ton ferme et rendez vous chez
concord music qui réfléchit qui prend un
temps mais si tu raisonnes comme ça tu
sortiras jamais été galère il se passe
un truc là t'as du buzz il faut que tu
en profites complètement là où à tiques
à pattes au breil mais cela serait
directement allez on va dire que nous y
sommes c'est plus la force tranquille
mais toi tu es le meilleur tu est
meilleur je pense que c'est une relation
fraternelle de deux mecs qui se
connaissent par coeur de clément qui est
un peu le chien fou dans l'es2 et
william qui est beaucoup plus dans le
contrôle et non dans la sagesse même si
c'est une sagesse qui est pas mature
donc elle est parfois un peu teinté de
maladresse en fait tu sais rien quoi
bateau temps clément là je parle comme
si c'était ma faute ce qui se passe là
atteint j'irai peut-être à il est
presque trop beau pour clément et pour
braine je pense qu'on est pas à faire
puisque même que se jeter à l'eau [ __ ]
je me raccroche au nez la livre est de
beaucoup
inès quand elle voit williams a débarqué
s est dit mme mais qui c'est celui là
mais pour qui se prend et en fin de
compte finalement elle se dias voulait
pas si con que ça sur un artiste
débutant classique c'est toujours ce
qu'on propose
oui mais un artiste débutant classique
il cartonne construit mais fut pas 7
millions de vues sur un christ est pas
être abondée d'accord non c'est une
jeune femme qui va qui va les
accompagner qui va vraiment les prendre
sous son aile auquel elle va elle va
s'attacher à elle va essayer
d'effectivement les embarque avec elle
dans son qui est qui et pas facile tu
risque de faire les choses pas bien si
tu fais les choses pas bien tu vas te
faire massacrer sur les réseaux sociaux
sauf qu'on a déjà c'est le truc sur
neutre ce qui m'a séduit dans ce
personnage
je pense que c'était déjà d'être une
femme une vraie pas une femme-enfant pas
une nana encore en pré puberté à dos ah
ouais d'accord donc le dire son option
chez vous le rap game c'est un milieu
d'hommes quand même et il n'est c'est
l'une des rares femmes à s'imposer mais
naturellement bon elle est garée ya trop
de monde à aller tous ceux qui
voudraient partager gauche allez on
dégage mais pour lui aussi tout ça dit
quoi or bien aussi toi c'est une boule
de feu qui sait où elle va qui sait ce
qu'elle veut qu'ils aient les moyens d'y
arriver c'est bon c'est tout du long et
massa n'importe quoi qui a pas du tout
cas pas du tout dans un rapport de
séduction d'ambiguïté avec avec les
hommes avec avec qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle en a pas besoin
c'est une femme assez
intelligente ça fait beaucoup là dessus
il ya comme ça qu'on verra qui tendent à
valider une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal